Welcome to Android TV Games.
Your game is going to look
awesome on the big screen.
Android TV is your opportunity
to develop for TV and
mobile at the same time and in the same
APK without much extra effort.
That's because Android TV is,
after all, just Android.
While this will not be a course on how
to develop a complete game from scratch,
we will teach you how to
extend your existing game to
also work on Android TV.
We'll show you how to
work with TV remotes and
game controllers using a simple
arcade game called Asteroids.
We'll also cover a variety of core and
advanced topics like nearby
connections for second screen input.
Ready?
Let's get started.